good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
yesterday some friends and I went to the
Indianapolis Motor Speedway and I got to
drive around the track with race car
driver Sara Fisher at 180 miles per hour
and experience profound fear joy which
would be a good name for a band but for
now the relevant thing is that while I
was going around the track I felt like
Sara Fisher was driving the Batmobile
and I was Robyn and that reminded me
that while I'm a big Sara Fisher fan I
kind of hate Batman like if I were a
billionaire the first thing I would do
would be to pledge 90% of my money to
charity then I would build my own
racetrack that Sara Fisher could drive
me around
they don't give AFC Wimbledon a bunch of
money so they could build a new stadium
then I build a huge house with lots of
secret rooms that you can only access by
touching certain books on a fake
bookshelf and then I would still be
super rich because a billion dollars is
a lot of money but I'm getting slightly
off-topic here a point being I got oh
they're gonna be a particularly good or
generous billionaire but one thing I
wouldn't do is spend a gajillion dollars
developing a Batmobile that only I am
allowed to drive I mean whoa k
spider-man got bit by a radioactive
spider he has to be spider-man he
doesn't have a choice he can't stop
shooting webs so you might as well use
that skill to aid the police similarly
Sailor Moon didn't choose to be an alien
princess from silver millennium but
Batman is just a rich guy with an
affinity for bats who's playing out his
insane fantasy of single-handedly
ridding Gotham of crime how is that
heroic now I know what you're saying
Hank iron man and fair enough Tony Stark
is a billionaire who could use his
wealth a little bit better and that's a
story unto itself about how the
superhero is elevated by each generation
say a lot about that generation but at
least iron man has that weird nuclear
bomb heart thing built with the help of
the token good and therefore doomed arab
guy and he's like all i should use my
nuclear heart for good it's not much but
it's something
meanwhile can you really argue that
batman is good for Gotham I mean in the
Batman universe crime is caused by one
evil people who just want to see the
world burn and two stupid people who
follow the evil but charismatic cat
person / Joker / penguin God the
villains and Batman are terrible also
slightly off-topic but I would argue
that Catwoman despite her jewelry
thieving etc is by almost any measure
much more heroic than Batman
but anyway crime is not actually caused
by evil it's caused by systemic
disenfranchisement and poverty and lack
of access to job opportunities and
education and yet Batman continues on
not funding Police Department's or
schools or building low-income housing
but
tearing up the infrastructure of the
city he claims to love while fighting
villains who are only powerful because
that city is already so blighted and
dysfunctional I'm sorry I'm losing my
temper but this Batman understand how
difficult it is for an underfunded city
like Gotham to replace roads and bridges
anyway it seems to me that one of the
more realistic facets of the Batman
sagas is that Gotham never gets better
for long after Batman's villain
destroying exploits like Batman saves
Gotham over and over and over again but
he never actually improves it all so why
does no one ever call Batman out for
devoting all of his resources to
fighting crime in Gotham when he can
also be fighting I don't know global
poverty or habitat destruction or
climate change Janek I'm not saying that
cleaning up the streets of Gotham isn't
a worthy goal for a billionaire but to
reiterate he's bad at it I will say this
think Batman has inspired some great
graphic novels and some very good movies
all of which go to extraordinary lengths
to make it seem like bad things just
keep happening to Batman so he has to
develop a massive arsenal that he keeps
in a Batcave but it's the question at
the core of the Batman story still
bothers me why do we celebrate the
vigilante ambitions of individual
billionaires surely we understand that
the real work among humans is done not
in isolation but in collaboration we do
understand that right and no I am NOT
just saying all of this because my hair
looks more and more like Wolverines by
the day Hank I will see you on Friday